today's sponsor is blue Chu and they're
giving you your first shipment totally
free all you have to do is pay five
dollars for shipping go to blue chewed
comm use promo code David I've put the
link right underneath this video we had
a bunch of interesting elections
yesterday a very important reminder
useful reminder that we don't just have
a presidential race going on right now
we have 435 House seat elections coming
up in November
many primaries for those happening in
the months leading up we have 35 Senate
elections and the possibility that
Democrats would be able to take over the
Senate we've looked at that and
yesterday there were a bunch of
interesting primaries that I want to
talk about today not at all surprisingly
congresswoman Alexandria Castillo Cortes
had a primary challenger who she easily
defeated the Challenger was Michele
Caruso Cabrera a CNBC host former
Republican running now as the Democrat
and AOC easily won as of right now looks
like AOC had about 73 percent of the
vote in that race because that's such a
blue district the primary is essentially
the general election like there will be
a Republican on the ballot against AOC
in November but the fact that she won
the primary all but guarantees that AOC
will get a second term in the House of
Representatives another race that we
were watching very closely and we'll
continue to watch closely now that we
have a primary winner is the Democratic
challenger against Senate Majority
Leader Mitch McConnell for his Kentucky
Senate seat Mitch McConnell has been one
of the most successful Republicans from
the the the measurement from the
standpoint of what he's been able to
achieve as many of you know a an
excellent and effective tool for the
right in getting a bunch of judges
confirmed holding off holding open a
seat on the Supreme Court that should
have been Barack Obama's to replace with
Merrick garland obstructing Mitch
McConnell that seat for long enough that
Donald Trump ended up getting to choose
Neel Gore such an incredible coup
victory
Republicans horrible for the world
horrible for the country never should
have been allowed to happen but if
you're a Republican certainly Mitch
McConnell has been effective he has a
serious primary challenge and Amy
McGrath seemed to be the leader going
into the primary over the last couple of
weeks there was some energy around
Charles Booker a more progressive
alternative in the Democratic primary
but indeed Amy McGrath has won there
with about 45% of the vote
that's a plurality charles booker only
with about 36% of the vote so we will
see Amy McGrath challenge Mitch
McConnell we've said before it's a very
uphill battle but even getting Mitch
McConnell to have a fight even of
forcing Republicans nationally to have
to spend money to defend Mitch McConnell
seat is great and she could actually win
Amy McGrath was up by one point a tie
within the margin of error statistically
speaking a couple of weeks ago that's
going to be a great one to watch
interesting Republican primary in North
Carolina to mention where a 24-year old
guy defeated the Trump endorsed
candidate in the Republican primary for
a House seat his name is Madison Kath
ORN Trump endorsed his opponent Linda
Bennett this is the 11th congressional
district in North Carolina that's the
seat that was formerly held by Trump's
now latest chief of staff mark Meadows
who's a horrible horrible guy
unofficially Cawthorne won very easily
by about a 75 to 25 margin this is a
notable defeat for the Trump endorsed
candidate but it's important to remember
that the guy that won Cawthorne he also
loves Trump is it Trump endorsed the his
opponent but this is not like an anti
Trump Republican that one Catherine
loves Trump it's just that Trump picked
somebody else so either way if he wins
in November it's still horrible
interestingly he's not even old enough
to serve as of right now but because he
will be 25 by the time he would be
inaugurated he's allowed to be on the
ballot he will
go on to face the Democratic candidate
mo Davis and that's a Republican leaning
district so at a sort of background
level at a base level that that is one
that favors Republicans there are four
congressional candidates who support
Medicare for all who won primaries
yesterday Ritchie Torres Jamaal Bowman
Mondt Air Jones and Dana Balter so
that's interesting and important and
we'll see what happens with their races
in November and then a really
interesting story out of Virginia dr.
Cameron Webb I call him WebMD that's how
I refer to him but officially dr.
Cameron Webb he have won the Democratic
primary in Virginia's fifth District and
he will probably face off against
Republican Bob good in November that
would be a really great seat to turn
from red to blue Webb ran hugely on
affordable health care he's a physician
he was leading with 68% of the vote last
I checked so that's a big win for him
that actually is a traditionally
Republican district which is flippable
and Virginia has been a what I call it
Virginia has been a realistic focus of
going blue we've seen many elements of
Virginia go blue over the last eight 10
years and officially that race leans
Republican but it is a winnable seat and
we'll just have to see how the campaign
shakes out it's a wild district in that
last election cycle Republican Denver
Riggleman won the seat by about 6 points
and then was removed by the local
Republican convention because he
officiated a gay wedding for two of his
old friends and campaign staffers which
is it it Virginia's been getting pulled
blue it is still Virginia and this stuff
still exists there so a number of
interesting races this ties into how
will we vote in November and the
discussions of absentee ballots and vote
by mail we'll be talking about that
later today the desire for scientists
and educators and doctors at least on
the Democratic side it seems partial
to be related to what we've been seeing
with coronavirus and the failed federal
response in the United States and that's
exactly where I want to go next I hate
that I was correct I I really do but
months ago I told you other countries
are getting coronavirus under control we
are not it is looking more and more like
at some point travel is going to open
back up Asia to Europe Europe to to
wherever you know it doesn't matter
Europe to Australia and the United
States is likely to be banned from
entering a lot of these countries why
because they've got it under control
we don't and they don't want us bringing
the disease there and unfortunately that
is exactly what is happening Europe
reportedly plans according to a report
in the New York Times to ban American
travelers indefinitely because we are
failing hard on coronavirus now when I
say that we're failing we haven't all
failed that that's the reality some of
the best places in the world to be right
now places that have seen the most rapid
decrease in cases are in the United
States I am fortunate to live in one of
those places Massachusetts but on the
other side of the coin many of the worst
places to be in the world are in the
United States and if you are Switzerland
or you are Spain or France
you can't practically speaking say
people from Massachusetts can fly here
but people from Arizona can't and the
United States is going to be judged by
our worst performing States and
unfortunately the worst performing
States right now are some of the worst
places in the world to be so what's
going on is that on July 1st Europe is
going to reopen its borders to
international travelers and they've put
together a list of countries that are
not going to be allowed to come in
people from countries that are not going
to be allowed to come in the list is
still being finalized the United States
is reportedly on the list
China is believed to be on the list of
Uganda Cuba Vietnam it looks like Brazil
and Russia which are disastrous hotspot
they are believed to be on the list now
on a personal level this bothers me but
that's not what this is really about I
mean I was hoping I was planning to
maybe be able to go to Europe at the end
of summer if things were better there
and things were better here but they're
terrible here at the national level and
so I'm not going to be allowed to go
okay you know sad for me but there's a
much bigger picture here because this is
a huge blow to the prestige and respect
of the United States around the world
we've already been a laughingstock since
Donald Trump was elected it's gotten
worse and worse and worse and this is
really an indictment of the job that
Donald Trump has done or maybe better
said not done on the issue of
coronavirus Trump is so unstable we know
how he's going to react to this and it's
really tragic how terribly some parts of
our of our country are doing for example
if you look at Spain you see that their
cases have just fallen off a cliff such
small numbers in Spain lately you look
at Switzerland Switzerland has
absolutely crushed the curve looks
amazingly good I could go on giving you
more and more examples in New Zealand
you know but many places in Europe and
around the world here in the United
States there are places that are looking
very good one of the places that has
seen the fastest decline in cases I'm
proud to say I'm happy to say is right
here in the the Commonwealth of
Massachusetts where we are doing very
well and you know we could say hey
listen we have an airport we have all
sorts of flights to Europe but sadly
because anybody can just come to
Massachusetts from Florida or Arizona or
Texas we're not going to be allowed into
Europe and indeed when you look at the
numbers in some of these other states
you look at Texas Texas set a new record
each over the last two days Texas had
more than 5,000 coronavirus cases two
days in a row the last couple of days in
Florida around 3500 cases per day in
fact they've been there for close to a
week
yesterday's Trump rally location which
we will discuss later Arizona hitting
their single day record yesterday same
day as the Trump rally doesn't really
bode well
ten days from now but more than
35-hundred new cases in Arizona
yesterday for the first time so we have
to realize that we are the bad eggs here
we are that country that around the
world along with Brazil and Russia and
India I mean we're not unique in this
way but we are one of the worst we are
one of those bad eggs that around the
world they say hey we're doing well many
countries are doing well let's start to
restart economies and let people in but
we've got to keep the bad actors out we
are one of the bad actors right now now
this should not come as a shock our
president admitted on Saturday that he
wanted testing slowed down he confirmed
it yesterday I'll have video for you
later so when you hear the president
wanted less testing it shouldn't come as
a huge surprise that we're not doing so
well
now I hesitate to even open up this can
of worms because it's being considered
I'm going to mention it there is the
possibility that some of the states that
are doing better are going to look at
banning travel from other American
states this is very complicated legally
because of the law a Paul V Virginia
from I believe 1869 the supreme court
defined freedom of movement in the
United States as right of free ingress
to other states and egress from them and
that seems very cut and dry but there's
many different layers and overlapping
precedent when it comes to what is there
in terms of what states can do to say
we're not letting people in from Florida
or we're not letting people in from
Texas there are discussions happening
about northeastern states saying we
don't want people coming here from those
other places could be Massachusetts New
York is looking at it is it possible
that if certain states did that they
would be allowed to send people to
Europe on planes we don't know and it
really depends more on Europe than it
does on on us the legal questions are
complex this is also going to cause
absolute and total chaos and it is going
to start to
very ugly in the United States if you
start seeing and it's being considered
now certain states saying we are sort of
going to isolate our state as if it were
its own country and I mean listen I'll
maybe leave it there for now if that
happens there will be many more
conversations to have before we go to
the break I want to say thank you we had
something very special happened
yesterday on the show yesterday even
doing the show for years and years and
years yesterday the same day right June
23rd we had our best day for the audio
podcast ever you go back to the start of
the audio podcast we had more listens to
the audio podcast yesterday than ever in
david pakman show history also yesterday
on the same day we had more people watch
our clips on Facebook than ever before
so yesterday was the best day in the
David Pakman show history storied
history controversial history ever in
terms of Facebook views and podcast
downloads and I just have you guys to
thank I so appreciate it we're going to
be taking a couple days off the rest of
this week they kind of put together a
nice four-day weekend I think everybody
deserves it we've been going straight
through really since we got back from
the end of 2019 break because if
coronavirus there's nowhere to go so
we've been going straight through so
we'll be taking some much-needed time
off for the next couple days I'll be
coming to you from a very special
location next week and then we'll do one
extra day off around the fourth of July
weekend but thank you to everybody let
me know where where your state is in
terms of the virus I'm on twitter at D
Pakman we'll take a quick break and be
back after this the david pakman show at
david pakman.com
[Music]
this episode was sponsored by blue Chu
giving my viewers their first shipment
totally free when you go to blue to calm
and use promo code David it's just a
reality that many men regardless of age
can sometimes benefit from a boost in
confidence a little bit of performance
help blue chew is the first chewable
tablet with the same fda-approved
ingredients as Viagra and Cialis blue to
being a chewable tablet means it starts
working twice as fast as a pill it's
prescribed online you spend a couple
minutes with a short questionnaire a
licensed doctor reviews the information
decides if a prescription is right for
you it's then shipped directly to your
home in discreet packaging no awkward
visits to the doctor's office or
pharmacy plus it's also cheaper than
getting it at a pharmacy when you go to
blue chewed calm and use promo code
David you will get your first shipment
completely free just pay $5 shipping
that's promo code David you get your
first shipment of blue 2 completely free
and I've put the link right underneath
this video
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com today's new members of the
day are phoebe spore and Gisela Katla
big thanks to Phoebe and Gisela I so
appreciate your support and I also want
to say thanks to today's longtime
sustaining member of the day it's Milton
maguro milton's been a member almost 5
years I'm inviting you right now this is
the invitation to grab a membership at
join pakman.com we are mostly funded
primarily funded by viewers and
listeners who sign up at join pakman.com
okay it's been a couple weeks since
we've had any hatred mail on the program
now there's been no shortage of me
receiving it we've just had so many
stories to cover I do want to get some
hatred mail in front of you today just a
quick reminder about what hatred mail is
why don't you take some
hydroxychloroquine for that trump
derangement syndrome patriot mail
written by Patriots who hate David
Pakman because America and because
freedom okay
let's get right into it this is us you
know we've seen a lot of disregard Ford
disregard for the Constitution and the
First Amendment and the rule of law
lately from people who claim to be
constitutional conservatives that's the
context through which we should consider
today's hatred mail see what you fail to
realize David Park man is that your talk
pisses off a lot of patriotic Americans
your talk is treason and you should be
tried and executed and it's punks like
you who will get the coming Civil War
started guess what happens then you
[ __ ] traitor
you are held accountable for your
treasonous words yeah so if there's
going to be a civil war it will be
because the people who would still be on
the pro-slavery Confederacy today are
going to take up guns and try to start a
civil war the Civil War is not going to
be started by people who want health
care for everybody right the civil
is not going to be started by those who
believe that we should have proper
oversight and reform of police
departments that's civil war is going to
be from people who still think that the
Confederacy was the right side of the
actual Civil War and it seems it's not
just it's not just Trump throwing around
the word treason as he did yesterday
about Barack Obama it's also hatreds
that are doing it remember that you can
fight hate reott ism by using the coupon
code hay tree at 40 we have this code
hay tree at 40 it chops 40% off of the
cost of a membership on my website and
the hatreds cry every time it's used
it's spelled h 8e r io T for 0 let's
talk a little bit about Noam Chomsky
Noam Chomsky's a linguist and a
philosopher he's now 91 years old and
he's had some pretty damn good takes
lately that have unfortunately really
rattled and shaken up a slice of the
American left-wing that's very very anti
Joe Biden so as an example a few months
ago maybe it was a month ago Noam
Chomsky said of course I'm going to vote
for Joe Biden and everybody should vote
for Joe Biden and that was the take and
it was not particularly controversial
but there were a lot of people who were
very upset with Noam Chomsky saying that
he has sold out in some way but I was
glad to hear him say it because there's
definitely crossover between Bernie fans
and Chomsky fans and not all of them
agree that voting Trump out to replace
him with Biden is good now I believe
that that is good that is the right
decision to make so does Noam Chomsky
Noam Chomsky was recently interviewed by
Michael Brooks who has some clips on our
channel if you go back in the archives a
little bit and Chomsky said Trump is
undeniably the worst criminal in history
and what I like about this is that
Chomsky has shown a commitment not to
allow the forest to be missed for the
trees when people start getting into
well you know back in the
90s Biden didn't take Social Security
cuts off the table so that means he's
running today on cutting Social Security
you know it's like hold hold on a second
hold on a second
Biden is not running on cutting Social
Security today in the 90s Biden said I
wouldn't preemptively take it off the
table in a negotiation while I disagree
with what Biden said in the 90s that was
almost 30 years ago and he's not running
on that now and Trump is an evil madman
who must be removed Noam Chomsky has
been very good at distilling that every
time he's asked about this and he does
it here in this interview as well let's
look at a sort of condensed transcript
and I actually want to read through it
because this really matters Noam Chomsky
said quote this sounds strong but it's
true Trump is the worst criminal in
history undeniably there has never been
a figure in political history who was so
passionately dedicated to destroying the
projects for organized human life on
earth in the near future this is not an
exaggeration people are focused now on
the protests the pandemic is serious
enough that we will emerge from it at a
terrible cost the cost is greatly
amplified by the gangster in the White
House who has killed tens of thousands
of Americans making this the worst place
in the world for the coronavirus we will
emerge from the pandemic but we're not
going to emerge from another crime that
Trump has committed the heating of the
globe the worst of it is coming we're
not going to emerge from that the ice
sheets are melting they're not going to
recover that leads to exponential
increase in global warming Arctic
glaciers for example could flood the
world recent studies indicate that on
the present course in about 50 years
much of the habitable part of the world
will be unlivable you won't be able to
live in parts of South Asia parts of the
Middle East parts of the United States
we're approaching the point of a hundred
and twenty five thousand years ago when
sea levels were about 25 feet higher
than they are now
and it's worse than that The Scripps
oceanographic institute just came out
with a study that estimated that we are
coming ominously close to a point
similar to 3 million years ago when sea
levels were 50
280 feet higher than they are today
Noam Chomsky goes on to say quote all
around the world countries are trying to
do something about it but there is one
country which is led by a president who
wants to escalate the crisis to raced
toward the abyss to maximize the use of
fossil fuels including the most
dangerous of them and to dismantle the
regulatory apparatus that limits their
impact there is no crime like this in
human history nothing this is a unique
individual and it's not as if he doesn't
know what he's doing of course he does
it's as if he doesn't care if he can
pour more profits into his pockets and
the pockets of his rich constituency
tomorrow who cares if the world
disappears in a couple of generations as
far as the government is concerned we're
seeing something pretty interesting
parliamentary democracy has been around
for 350 years starting in England in
1689 with the so-called Glorious
Revolution when sovereignty was
transferred from the royalty to the
Parliament the beginnings of
parliamentary democracy in the u.s. came
about a century later parliamentary
democracy is not just based on laws and
constitutions in fact the British
constitution is maybe a dozen words it's
based on trust and good faith the
assumption that people will act like
human beings and then after Chomsky
talks a little bit about Richard Nixon
and George W Bush Chomsky goes back to
quote it goes deep into issues well
before Trump but he is a unique
phenomenon again the worst criminal in
human history
so his minor crimes are to destroy
American democracy and to amplify a
pandemic killing over a hundred thousand
people but those are minor crimes by his
standards
what's so important about this is that
Chomsky distills the importance of not
messing around with these sidebar
arguments what we're seeing is as bad as
I and others have been saying much of it
the incompetence the authoritarian
tendencies the ruined glow
alliances the worsening crisis crisis of
climate change while Trump doesn't care
they were all completely predictable
from day one and I was not unique in
predicting it I'm not taking any unique
credit for predicting it this is not a
time for maybe I'll stay home or maybe I
don't care or I don't really like Biden
or whatever you contribute to the
worsening of the problem if you do that
that's how critical this is and I'm so
glad that we are hearing it from Noam
Chomsky we'll have some of these Chomsky
quotes on the show's instagram page at
david pakman show make sure you're
following us there also make sure you're
following me on instagram at david
pakman I posted a video of how I now
drink water might be interesting to some
of you the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]
the David Pakman show depends on your
support and the easiest way is through
membership which includes the
world-famous bonus show as well as
commercial free audio and video streams
of the show just for members sign up
today at join pakman.com coupon code
saves you 40% vote soon 18 welcome back
to the David Pakman show this is very
interesting Donald Trump said during an
interview this week that yes he is
planning to get people a second stimulus
check Trump was interviewed by Joe st.
George he was asked about a second
stimulus check and he said that that's
the plan he wouldn't say when or for how
much let's take a look at that bit of
the interview I have a lot of viewers in
Florida Ohio Wisconsin Michigan who are
still struggling economically sir they
spent all of that first stimulus check
are you gonna get them a second stuff
yeah we are we are look we had this when
when are you gonna get it we had this
going better than anybody's ever seen
before we had the best job numbers the
best economics the best economy we've
ever had and then we had the virus come
in from China and now we're rebuilding
it again we will be doing another
stimulus package it'll be very good
it'll be very generous and how much how
much how much people want to know you'll
find out about it your flood when are
you gonna do it when you go to announce
I think over the next I think it's gonna
be bipartisan I think it's going to be
over the next couple of weeks now this
is fascinating for a few different
reasons you might remember that about a
month ago maybe it was five weeks ago it
was pretty clear that the Trump
administration didn't really have the
appetite for another round of payments
another stimulus check and I think that
there were two reasons for that first of
all there were so-called economic
concerns about the cost of doing another
stimulus check a lot of the people on
Trump's side politically are a so-called
debt and deficit hawks even though they
don't really understand those those
mechanisms economically but it seemed
that that was part of the lack of
appetite but maybe even more importantly
they were against committing to a second
round of
the Millis checks four to six weeks ago
because they wanted to pretend that
everything would be fine by now and back
to normal and that you simply wouldn't
need another round of stimulus checks
now of course this is very much not the
case and in fact a ton of people
entitled to their first check haven't
even received it 35 million stimulus
checks are still outstanding as of
mid-june and at the same time Trump
can't say or he won't say how much money
would be included in the second stimulus
and the reason he can't say that is the
truth is it's not clear that Republicans
want to do another round of stimulus and
to me this signals what's going on
behind the scenes
Democrats want stimulus because
Democrats think people deserve it given
how bad the situation with the
coronavirus continues to be many
Republicans don't want another stimulus
because their so-called debt and deficit
hawks Trump only wants a second stimulus
because he sees the polls and he's
panicking and as more checks go out he
envisions that he is essentially buying
himself more votes that's really what's
going on here and there are even some
officials in the Trump administration
that are not on board with doing another
round of stimulus it's not clear
Republicans in the House are going to go
for it it's not clear Republicans in the
Senate are going to go for it either
there have been some internal
discussions where Trump has said
straight up
he believes sending out more checks will
help boost the economy and help him get
reelected in the fall like but period
full stop end of story which is exactly
what it seems to be to me Stephen
minuchin has been in favor of another
round of checks Trump's economic advisor
Larry Kudlow seems to have been opposed
Senate Majority Leader Mitch McConnell
has been against another round of
payments Democrats want even larger
payments than the first time around and
Donald Trump here seems to be with the
Democrats not for economic reasons not
for moral reasons but because he
believes sending checks out again will
help get him reelected in November Trump
is effectively trying to buy his way to
re-election with another round of check
the right loves to attack the left as
wanting to buy people's votes with
things like health care and properly
funded education for example now those
arguments are quite silly what we're
talking about is establishing a well-run
society given that we're one of the
richest countries in the world much like
many northern European countries have
been able to do but Trump is actually
saying allegedly behind the scenes if we
start sending checks out to people I'm
gonna get more people to vote for me now
the other thing here is Trump may be
setting himself up to say look I wanted
another round of checks but they
wouldn't okay it they will be framed as
Democrats even though here Democrats do
want it and it seems like it's
Republicans that aren't actually
interested in terms of the timing
there's a bit of a conundrum July 3 to
17 is what's called a state work period
for the Senate meaning they will be in
their states rather than in Washington
DC so what this means is there's no way
this gets done before July 3rd I mean
we've got you know before July 3rd we
have the next three days then we've got
a weekend and then we have a few days
next week you're not going to pass
another round of stimulus checks before
next Friday
that means the conversation won't even
really be meaningful until after the
Senate returns after July 17th so if
this process starts on July 17 when
could this even potentially be done are
we looking at August are we looking at
September and remember 35,000,000 still
haven't gotten their first check or
deposited which means that even if you
get this passed in late July or August
you could have people who still will
have not received their checks until
close to the presidential election in
November so I don't know whether it can
even be done it doesn't seem Trump wants
it for any reason other than he sees it
as a way to buy himself some votes and
we also have no idea what might even be
going on by the time that this actually
gets done in late July early August we
may not even have a break between waves
1 and 2 in coronavirus as we see the
virus continues to rage in many states
across the country very unpredictable
but Donald Trump now
panicking and saying yeah yeah yeah
let's get more checks to people and a
lot of this has to do with the polls
which I want to talk about next we have
interesting new polls from the last two
days they are both terrible for Donald
Trump but I actually want to do a little
bit more of a deep dive and look at the
internals of one of these polls so big
picture two new polls Tuesday poll from
Harvard Harris says Biden is up 12 a
poll from the New York Times today says
Joe Biden is up 14 which is absolutely
stunning but let's focus in on some of
the details of today's New York Times
poll in this poll Joe Biden is up 50 to
36 that's a 14-point lead
you also have 14 percent of respondents
under the other category that includes
people planning to vote third party
people that are as yet undecided so you
still have a lot in that other category
now there are two particular areas that
are really hurting Donald Trump number
one is his response to coronavirus and
number two is Trump's handling of race
relations 60 percent of the country
believes Trump has mishandled
coronavirus that's important because it
is dramatically higher than Trump's
approval and it shows us that there is a
big net deficit that Trump is
experiencing thanks to his absolutely
disastrous handling of the virus that
includes among white voters and men
typically white voters and men favor
Trump even among white voters and men
there is significant dissatisfaction
with Trump's handling of coronavirus
then on race relations sixty-one percent
of voters say they disapprove of Trump's
handling of race only 33 percent approve
these are two of the most one-sided
areas where Trump is underwater now a
couple of other interesting things from
this poll Democrats and Republicans
right now according to the New York
Times poll equally support their party's
candidates
it is independents that are sort of
making the difference for Joe Biden so
take a look at this 85 percent of
Democrats say they're going to vote for
Joe Biden 85 percent of Republicans say
they're going to vote for Don
from that's even there are actually more
Republicans nationally than Democrats so
in a sense that favors Donald Trump but
independents are leaning towards Biden
by a 21 point margin which is huge and
then also interesting
the Trump campaign has been pushing the
idea that Biden is too old to be
President remember Trump turned 74 about
ten days ago
Joe Biden's 77 as of right now 60% of
voters disagree that Joe Biden is too
old so we don't know what's going to
happen between now and November but the
key numbers I'm looking at are number
one an incumbent president polling only
36 percent four months before the
election is not good number two OS and
let me say a little bit more about that
in head-to-head re-election campaign so
when you've had a strong third party
candidate the numbers are different when
you really have a head-to-head matchup
for president the worst-performing
incumbent president was John Adams who
got 39% of the vote in 1800 even the
wildly unpopular Herbert Hoover still
got 40% of the vote against FDR in 1932
I don't think Trump will be under 40 no
matter what but if Trump ends up with
anywhere close to where he's polling now
40 to 44 even 45 percent of the vote
this could be a historic defeat if we
actually go out and vote that's number
that's one metric that's important Trump
polling in the 30s four months before
the election the other really important
metric is that Joe Biden is regularly
polling over 50 percent fifty percent or
more in polls if you look at polling at
this point in 2016 Hillary Clinton was
only occasionally polling 50 percent and
when she was it really didn't go any
higher than 51 52 Joe Biden is regularly
polling 50% or even more and the reason
that matters is that the undecided vote
the unsure vote the third party vote as
you get closer to Election Day it often
will consolidate or
move towards the incumbent in this case
the incumbent is Trump what matters
about Biden regularly being at 50% or
more is that Biden doesn't need to get
any more support to win if we don't get
complacent and go out and vote we could
see the economy take up a little bit if
coronavirus gets under control it's only
a blow out in November if we go out and
vote and that's a real question mark so
now that we've looked at all the polls
what you should do is go out there
pretending as if every single one of
these polls says Trump is winning by one
right the idea the mentality you should
have is I don't care what the polls are
I need to act as if my vote alone could
give a State to Joe Biden of course it's
not literally the case but that's the
attitude that we should have and we'll
continue following the polls we'll
continue following Trump's internals
among independence on coronavirus on
race relations but in the end at the end
of the day we all need to say on
November 3rd what would I be doing right
now if my vote could be the vote that
swings this election from Trump to Biden
oh I'd go out and vote that's exactly
what I'm going to do and of course many
of us will vote early many of us will be
voting absentee and that just means we
have the opportunity to lock our vote in
even sooner we don't even have to wait
until November 3rd the david pakman show
at david pakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show depends on the
support of our viewers and listeners and
one way to keep us going is through
patreon where you can pledge as little
as one dollar per month or as much as
you want at patreon.com slash david
pakman show great perks and benefits as
well read about him the david pakman
show at david pakman.com
okay so we're continuing to talk about
testing and Donald Trump has now
confirmed that he was not kidding when
he said slow down coronavirus testing
the White House has been tripping all
over itself for days to say Trump was
just joking
Trump was then asked were you joking and
he said I don't kid and yet the White
House just keeps saying oh he's kidding
he's kidding
this is borderline criminal and it's
definitely murderous and I want to be
sure that you have all of the facts to
understand this story so I'm going
instead of going through this story
however else I might do it I'm going to
go through the story chronologically for
you okay so the start of the story is
the United States failed on coronavirus
testing from day one the u.s. and South
Korea got our first cases at the same
time within hours of each other we
didn't develop a test quickly we didn't
roll out a test quickly we didn't
contact trace and isolate South Korea
did they dominated the virus we are
leading in cases and deaths so that's
like the quick summary that gets us to
Saturday Saturday at his Corona rally in
Tulsa Oklahoma Trump admitted for the
first time I told them to do less
testing in order to find fewer cases
this is from Saturday tests of when you
do testing to that extent you're gonna
find more people you're gonna find more
cases so I said to my people slow the
testing down please
they test and they test we had tested
people don't know what's going on we got
this we got another one over here so
this is of course completely outrageous
it's a president admitting that for
political reasons he asked for something
that leads to more death the White House
reaction was he was just kidding
spokespeople said it was just a joke
representatives said it was sarcasm
so then on Monday Jo st. George
interviews Trump and asks him did you
order
coronavirus testing to be slowed down
Trump doesn't really answer the question
but he does say a lot of words take a
look
on Saturday night you said that you told
your staff to slow the testing down to
improve the numbers does that mean
someone watching this right now when
their local news is not going to get a
test because you asked you we do more
testing than any country in the world by
far twenty five million tests other
countries do 1 million every time you do
a test as you do more tests it shows
more and more cases so we're so far
advanced both in terms of the quality
and the amount and we're doing all these
tests and it shows cases if other
countries aren't doing or if we did slow
it down we wouldn't show nearly as many
cases so here Trump doesn't deny that he
asked for less testing he simply says if
we did less testing we'd have fewer
cases and again reporters ask the White
House and the Trump campaign did he
really order testing to be slowed down
because he didn't deny it he was given
the chance by Joe st. George to deny it
and he did not deny it and the White
House again says it's a joke the
campaign says he was kidding
etc etc so finally yesterday
Donald Trump is asked straight-up were
you kidding because people are saying
you were kidding were you kidding and
Trump says I don't kid
[Music]
[Applause]
I don't kid let me just tell you let me
make it clear we have got the greatest
testing program anywhere in the world so
Trump goes into the same talking point
again but the key phrase is I don't kid
he was not kidding when he asked for
testing to be slowed down he was not
kidding when he said that he asked for
testing to be slowed down are they also
going to say that him saying he doesn't
kid was a form of kidding like what's
left at this point from this crumbled
attempted defense of Donald Trump he's
given chance after chance he's presented
with opportunity after opportunity to
improve his answer like it's a do-over
in a sense and he just restates what he
said on Saturday night he could clarify
oh well you know why I meant this other
thing he doesn't change it at all
because it's the truth it's like being
allowed to retake a test after you're
given all the answers and you still put
down all the same wrong answers from
when you first took the test I got an
email saying David is this is this a
confession to negligent homicide
Trump is admitting that he asked for
something to be done which he thought
would be good politically which leads to
more deaths I mean maybe I just don't
even think this is the right direction
to go like Trump is not going to be held
criminally liable in any way here we
essentially have you know I mean it's
kind of depressing but for for a couple
years now I've been saying
November 3rd 2020 is when we will have
the opportunity to give him a
consequence we're talking about him like
he's a little boy who's misbehaved
because essentially that's how he
behaves the it wasn't going to be the
Russia investigation it wasn't going to
be impeachment it's not going to be
removal under the 25th amendment by his
cabinet for being unfit the opportunity
for a consequence is November 3rd and
all of these disasters and tragedies are
valid reasons to remove him and
hopefully we will do it because it's
really
the only opportunity that we have okay
so yesterday Donald Trump had a had a
rally indoors at a mega church in
Arizona you might be wondering wait a
second let me check my notes Arizona
Arizona is one of the worst-case growth
coronavirus hot spots in the world never
mind the country does that is that the
right place to have a big indoor rally
and you would be right to ask that
question Arizona is the state indeed
with the largest percentage case
increase in the last week or so cases of
forty eight percent in the last eight
days in Arizona case is just spiking
hugely so what does the president do he
holds a rally indoors at a huge Church
in Arizona now before we even go further
people have been emailing me saying how
can a church hold a campaign event
churches are given nonprofit tax-exempt
status in exchange for not doing
politics churches aren't allowed to do
politics and here they are hosting a
Trump campaign event and I agree I don't
know what to tell you I mean these what
we do know is that the rules against
churches doing politics are rarely
enforced it is very rare that a church
will actually be punished for doing
politics despite churches doing politics
being banned so I just don't have an
answer it's just we have no
accountability now faced with questions
about the the prudence prudency prudence
I'm not sure based on the questions
about the wisdom of doing this rally in
Arizona given that cases are exploding
in Arizona the CFO of Dream City Church
this was held at dreams city church and
dream City Church has a CFO named
Brendan Zastrow
they posted a video saying we've
installed a new air filtration system by
the way manufactured by one of our
congregants and it kills 99.9% of
coronavirus now health experts and
anybody with common sense immediately
said that's not
that's an absurd claim to make Arizona
State University scientists said it's an
absurd claim to make quote Matthew
scotch warned quote this is absurd and
will not protect you but here's the
church saying that this is the situation
they've got a great air filtration
system that will kill coronavirus take a
look Kovach 19 here at Green City Church
we're probably first church in the
nation - yeah we've we've installed
clean air exp we have a local Arizona
company was technology developed by some
members of our church and we've
installed these units and it kills 99.9%
of kovat within 10 minutes they have
been in testing its nyan ization - Ison
it's a ionization of of the air and it
takes particulate out and Kovach cannot
live in that environment so when you
come into our auditorium 99% of Kovach
is gone
still if it was there in the first place
so you can know when you come here
you'll be safe and protected thank God
for great technology and thank God for
be proactive amen
bless you guys I like how it's not
ionization it's ionisation ionisation
but it's all BS pronounce it however you
want it's obvious now even if it were
true
that their eye on ization system kills
the virus in some abstract way if I'm
standing right next to somebody and they
don't have a mask and I don't have a
mask an air filtration system in the
ceiling or in the walls is not actually
going to protect me from the people that
are right next to me without masks so
it's wildly irresponsible it's absurd
and then there's the the rally itself
which was a complete and total farcical
gong show Trump was visibly sweaty and
disheveled the entire time slurring
badly a brought students up to speak
during the event who were used as
pathetic and horrible political props
everything about it was horrible Trump
again going with this racist kung-fu
name for coronavirus firing up the crowd
with it imagine cheering for this take a
look with co vid Devin Otis said
the other night did anybody see my
speech the other night on Saturday that
what I said the other night there's
never been anything where they have so
many names I could give you 19 or 20
names for that fret to get all different
names Wuhan kau Hans was catching on
coronavirus coming flew imagine 10 years
from now thinking back and saying hey
remember when we went to that rally and
Trump said come flu wasn't that great I
mean the place just absolutely loved it
and that's actually I think that you
know the focus really should be on the
number of people that love this racist
kung flu stuff there's a lot of focus
understandably on the fact that the
president is calling it come flu and
there should be focus on that because we
shouldn't have a pleasent president who
does that there's no question about it
but the audience was filled with people
who loved it that's the problem the
Trump saying it is a problem but if that
immediately repelled people from voting
for him we would say okay this is a
madman racist but nobody's voting for
him the crowd loved it the audience if
you listen to that clip the audience was
actually shouting out come flu Trump
started saying Wuhan virus Chinese virus
the crowd is yelling Kong flu they want
him to say it they're delighted by the
racism of it all and I think that we
want to distribute criticism fairly and
Trump saying this would not be nearly
the problem that it is were it not for
the fact that huge crowds of people
absolutely love it now here's Donald
Trump in the same rally yesterday a
railing against vote-by-mail saying
listen we voted in World War one and we
voted during World War two
absentee ballots are fine absentee
ballots are fine like I live in the
White House and if I can't get to
Florida or you live wherever you live
you can't
you have to go through a process some
people just can't make it to a polling
station and they have good reason but
they have to go through this process in
order to verify their identity people
went to the polls and voted during World
War one they went to the polls and voted
during World War two we can safely go to
the polls and vote during kovat 19 now
what's funny about this or scary is that
vote by mail is absentee ballots like
what were Trump seems not to get it but
what we're talking about is getting
everybody an absentee ballot it's just
more of them Trump seems to imagine that
if it's vote by mail it's different than
the absentee ballots that he used and
that he says are okay and then Trump
raises this issue about we voted during
World War one in World War two the wars
weren't contagious pandemics and
soldiers during those Wars did vote by
mail so it's it's like a completely
irrelevant claim that Donald Trump is
making Trump also as is very common now
during these rallies particularly ones
that are happening later in the day
Trump having trouble speaking here he is
talking about America's flounders it's
the same spirit that drove Americas from
wonders and then here's Donald Trump
unable to say deployed he says deplore
instead and that's why when rioting and
looting broke out in our nation's
capital I quickly deplore I came in I
deployed the National Guard very quickly
so it was a truly responsible mess but
the good news like if there's anything
even slightly reassuring about what
we're seeing is that Trump's polling is
suffering very very badly because of his
handling of coronavirus Trump is an
incumbent president four months out from
his reelection Cambell reelection and
most national polls have been polling in
the 30s okay that's a good sign in the
sense that he can't he's not as Teflon
as he was once believed to be on race
relations on coronavirus that new New
York Times poll we talked about earlier
he's
suffering badly so even though he was
able to fill a room with people cheering
for come flew up he is suffering in the
polls we just have to see whether it
holds through to November and that's why
I was very cautious earlier today when
talking about polling the good news is
maybe maybe he can't actually get away
with this stuff okay we have a voicemail
number that number is two one nine two
david p it's been a long time since we
heard from furious angry trumpets jimmy
from philly i know some people in the
audience like Jimmy from Philly
others don't it's been so long since we
heard from him then I want to give you a
little bit of a peek behind the curtain
into my day envision this I wake up I
come downstairs I make my breakfast I
make my cappuccino I bring it over and
sit down in front of my computer and
it's time to see who called in overnight
we've got 50 60 70 voicemails that came
in overnight at two one nine two david p
oh i see seven voicemails in a row from
Jimmy from Philly what's going on I'm
just gonna play them for you the imagery
is I'm sitting there with my cappuccino
listening to this take a listen
David Jimmy from Sony when are you gonna
unsaddle banned me from YouTube and I
don't want to hear that your moderators
date believe me there you tell them to
do it they on do it right come on David
you're running the show here you have a
team I'm the health works man yeah but
when we gonna get this shuttle on the
road here David what are you waiting for
so again shadow bear I have no idea what
Jimmy's talking about and he was just
relentlessly calling in about this take
a look at this David can be from Philly
I see him still shadow bands on your
lives yeah nice no idea what he's
talking about and just continuing to
Porter's give me from Philly
why are you gonna take me off shot oh
and that one don't even got cut off
here's another Jim baby kid Luke oh
you'll have the ball - announcer like
joint you are so disingenuous it's like
I have made my call I have no clue of
what Jimmy's even talking about
and then I'll just do one more there
were more but I'll just do one more for
you so so you couldn't call me out baby
and you're not gonna have a college yeah
I want my money back baby I don't even
know what money Jimmy's talking about
the last I was aware of was Jimmy had a
membership which he cancelled months ago
I think he said because he was he was
getting laid off or something like that
so that's a typical day for me preparing
for the show I I don't I don't envy me
please don't envy me we're gonna have a
great bonus show today we are going to
talk about Texas is now saying just stay
home Texas is wide open
right like Texas opened early and on
paper Texas is open but the governor now
that they're having 5,000 new cases a
day the governor is saying just stay
home in Texas we will talk about how in
July that enhanced unemployment that
$600 a week boost for coronavirus is
coming to an end and we'll talk about
the economic implications and we will
also talk on the bonus show today about
a state court decision that says police
don't police are not able to force you
to unlock your phone it's a very
interesting case when it comes to what
it means to do a search or seizure and
all of those stories and more will be on
today's bonus show get instant access by
becoming a member at join pakman.com
remember that I am now bookable
on Cameo I'm David Pakman on cameo and
lastly don't miss the daily audio
podcast you can take it with you
anywhere in your favorite podcast app
don't miss it record day yesterday for
the audio podcast very very exciting for
me
thanks so much for watching today's
episode just a reminder today's sponsor
blue chew is giving you your first
shipment completely free all you have to
do is pay five dollars shipping go to
blue to calm and use the promo code
David I've put a link right underneath
this video